DAN GALPIN: All right.
Thank you to
everyone-- you got up
so early this beautiful
Friday morning
after the fabulous
party we had last night.
And for everyone who
is attending virtually,
you know, I'm sorry
you missed out on it,
but I'm sure there's
plenty of footage and video
and all this kind
of stuff from that.
Because it was pretty
fun, and I'm sure
people are a little bleary-eyed.
So thank you to those
hardcore native developers
who came out here, and
let's see if this works.
I got lucky.
All right, so NDK
performance in an ART world.
How many people here
are NDK developers?
All right.
This is good.
I'm excited to
see so many people
out there who are doing this.
This is a labor of
love for me, this talk,
so I'm really glad
you guys are here.
And you know, there's a
lot of Android development
where you get to just
blissfully ignore
a lot of what's going on
in the operating system.
You know, "take the blue pill."
You don't really need
to know what's going on
and how the Matrix
is formed-- you just
get to go and code in a
nice, beautiful environment
in managed code.
But today, we're actually
going to take the red pill.
We're going to get a little
bit inside to how things work.
And I hope it's fun.
And whether or not it's useful
or not, you can tell me,
but at least hopefully we'll
all learn something from this.
And of course, when I'm
talking about native code,
I'm referring specifically to
unmanaged code that does not
use the Android runtime.
And one of the primary
reasons that people end up
creating this code
is that they already
have a bunch of working C code.
You know, when you have
a lot of code that works,
you create new code,
you just create bugs.
No one wants to do that.
Now, of course, your
legacy code might not
include support for really
awesome multiprocessing,
or might not have support
for NEON Intrinsics.
So even though it's awesome
that you have this legacy code,
you're not always
guaranteed to get
the best performance with it.
That being said,
performance-- there's
a lot of people who write NDK
code for performance reasons.
How many people are doing it for
performance reasons out there?
How about cross-platform
compatibility?
Let me just have
a show of hands.
OK, so it's about the same.
And a lot of that means, to
get the best performance,
you need to know about things
like the number of types
of cores, thermals
in the design.
Like, there's a lot
of different variables
to actually making sure you
have the best performance.
But oftentimes, native
code is your only option.
And of course,
reach-- you want to be
able to hit multiple platforms.
And C++ is just getting
better and better at isolating
the operating system for
you, which is awesome.
And finally, the NDK
has a few capabilities
that aren't yet available
inside of the runtime.
Now what I'm excited
about is that, actually,
if you look-- when I wrote this
talk, to get low-latency audio,
you had to use OpenSL.
And if you want to get the
absolute lowest-latency audio,
you still need to
use that, but I'm
really excited
that in Android N,
we actually are
now allowing people
to use Java to get pretty darn
good latency on their devices.
And of course, it's the
only way to access Vulkan,
the graphics API, right now.
And that just makes
a lot of sense.
If you've ever seen
how verbose Vulkan is,
you definitely don't want to
be making that many JNI calls
if you don't have to.
Not that it doesn't work.
So this is probably review
for you, a lot of you,
since you're all NDK people.
What exactly is it?
You know, it's a combination
of tools and headers
that allow Android development.
You know, all applications
are eventually
tied to managed code running
in the Android runtime,
and the Android framework
itself is written largely
in managed code.
Your libraries are ultimately
loaded into this framework,
typically from within
Java code, and they all
get to talk to a stable
application binary interface,
which then, of course, talks
to the native system libraries.
And this is important,
because a lot of people
are like, well, why can't I just
use all those other libraries
that are there?
And people have done
this, and that's
why compatibility breaks.
And we're actually--
one of the things
that we've added to
N is, if you actually
try to use any of those
internal libraries,
they will not work anymore.
We actually have
separate link spaces.
So there's good and
bad news to this.
The bad news is
you're actually going
to have to put things
like libpng into your app.
The good news is when you
put them into your app,
you are guaranteed to get your
version of libpng on Android N
and above.
While in previous
versions of Android,
that was not always the case.
So I think, in a way, it
solves a lot of problems.
All right.
So it's grown over the years.
And you know, it
started off in Cupcake,
and we added, you know,
media features and gaming
features and the ability to do
fully native applications-- you
know, lots of cool stuff.
Recently, however, we've
actually gone even further.
We've actually put RenderScript,
finally, into the NDK,
so there are bindings for that.
We've continued to expand
graphics with Vulkan.
And we've added a couple
of really interesting ones
in the latest
versions of the NDK--
we've added Trace,
Choreographer,
and Multinetwork.
And at least I'm going to
talk a little bit about Trace
and Choreographer in this one.
So in addition,
the NDK toolchain,
which is separate from
platform releases,
has its own set of
12 major releases
and many minor releases.
12 just came out this week,
if you haven't seen it.
And here are some
of the highlights.
We added STL pretty early
on, and then we fixed it.
We added more platforms,
like x86 and MIPS.
We had the Clang compiler in 8c
and the misunderstood ARM7 FP
in 9d, which we are actually
taking out of NDK level 12.
So 64-bit in 10, and in 11, we
finally transitioned to Clang
as our primary compiler,
and we've actually
deprecated the use of GCC.
In the middle there, we moved
to LLDB as our primary debugger.
But again, this talk
isn't just about the NDK.
It's also about ART.
So what I did was, I
was really curious.
Like, ART is a totally
different beast
than our previous runtime.
So how does it affect the NDK?
And so what I did is, I went
through the Perf-JNI article.
I mean, probably everyone's read
this Perf-JNI article, right?
Or if you haven't,
you really should.
Because the real question
I wanted to know was,
do these tips actually
make sense in an ART world?
And we're going to keep
a scorecard for both ART
and Dalvik for each
one of these tips.
And so let's go through them.
And we're going to
benchmark these.
I actually benchmarked
these with Google Caliper,
which is pretty cool.
It's actually what we use
inside of our CTS tests
for all of our benchmarking,
so it's about as good
as you can get.
We use it a lot
internally at Google
for doing all sorts
of benchmarking.
So if you ever want to set it
up, it's actually pretty cool.
You'll learn a little
bit about Android just
setting this thing up.
Hopefully, we'll make it more
user-friendly at some point
in the future.
And so the basics.
When you're using JNI to
reference managed objects,
you're actually taking
advantage of reflection.
They named it, of
course, because it
describes the ability for code
to inspect itself at runtime.
Now to access a class field,
we take the object reference
for the class and use reflection
to request a Field ID, My Name.
OK, and from our developer
training, here's what it says.
It is important to cache
class references, Field IDs,
and Method IDs, because
they're guaranteed valid
until the class is unloaded.
And that rarely happens.
And it's really easy
to catch if it does.
So let's look at our first
performance suggestion
and how it holds up under art.
So a nice way to
cache these IDs,
which nicely solves
the unload problem,
is just to put it in
the static initializer.
So there you go, you [? call ?]
like this one, nativeInit.
Inside of that, you
get all your Field IDs.
So as you see, I'm making
a native call inside
of my static initializer,
which is kind of slick, right
after unloading the library.
And now those IDs
are good forever.
So it's really nice if
a class gets unloaded,
the static initializer
will get called again.
And here's how it benchmarks.
And it turns out,
now this is a Nexus 5
running KitKat in Marshmallow.
But as we can see, both
GetFieldID and GetIntField
are actually slower in ART.
In other words, the advice
to cache Field and Method IDs
is actually more important
in the world of ART
than it was in the
world of Dalvik.
And we'll see a trend here.
And the difference in the
cost of [? GetItField ?]
is a little surprising.
Both run times actually
change the state
of the internal thread.
And that's actually what costs
a bit of performance here,
although ART actually
clarifies what
it's doing with Scoped Object
Access rather than Scoped JNI
thread state.
And what we're seeing
is a couple of things.
One is that ART is pretty
complicated by comparison
to Dalvik.
And it's got a
lot more going on.
The garbage collector is
much more sophisticated.
It's much higher performance.
And the other thing is it's
just being really defensive.
There were definitely
times in Dalvik
where you could
cause it to deadlock.
And it's very, very difficult
to make ART do that.
So that's the beautiful
thing about all this work.
But it does cost us a little
in actual performance.
So this is something to note.
Also, I love this use
of the preprocessor
to prevent all this
duplicated code.
OK, as far as caching
Field Method IDs go,
it's a big win on Dalvik.
It's even a bigger win on ART.
So let's look at our second
performance suggestion,
and we'll see how it holds up.
If possible, it
is usually faster
to operate with UTF-16 strings.
Android does usually not require
a copy in GetStringChars,
whereas Get blah blah blah.
OK, I don't have to
read that to you.
Basically, it makes sense if
we don't have to copy strings,
it's going to be faster, right.
So here are the two
calls to get a string.
You can either get
the UCS string,
which is a 16-bit standard
format for the managed
side of things.
And UTF, which is, of course,
what a lot of our native code
expects.
And we would expect that if
there's no conversion going on,
that actually the UTF
would outperform the UCS.
OK, so let's take a look at
how this actually benchmarks.
And this was a little
surprising to me
because this was a short
15 character string.
And it turns out that
it was actually faster
to send the 8-bit decoded
string across instead
of the 16-bit string on ART.
On Dalvik, you can
see it actually
benches the way you
kind of expect it to.
But even then, it's
very, very close.
And it was a little
bit of a surprise.
And so I was like, OK,
I've got to understand
why this is happening.
So basically, I was
like, let's first of all,
try a longer string and see if
it actually behaves correctly.
So with a longer
string, we actually
see, yes, this actually
benches out the way we expect.
But it's a little surprising.
So let's look at the code and
see what actually is going on.
So you can see
inside of ART, there
is this line called
IsMoveableObject.
And it sometimes
gets to return a copy
and sometimes returns
the original string.
And IsMoveableObject is actually
kind of an expensive call.
So what ends up
happening is that this
is actually a for loop
inside of here, that
goes inside this fine
continuous space from object.
And that's actually
what takes the time.
So ultimately on ART, for a
lot of normal string sizes,
you might actually be better
just sending in the UTF-8
today.
Now of course, this is
all subject to change.
And maybe they'll watch this
and be like, oh god, we've
got to fix that.
But at least today, it
doesn't matter all that much,
as it turns out.
So that was a little
bit surprising.
And again, this is
a micro-benchmark.
So it certainly isn't going
to help prevent garbage.
[AUDIO OUT]
Is this working?
All right.
Fortunately, for all you
people on the live stream,
I've got a microphone.
So on our JNI tip scorecard,
it's probably a decent idea
to do it on both.
But it's definitely,
definitely better on Dalvik.
Finally, let's get
one more tip here.
And this is actually
me paraphrasing
because I couldn't come up
with a quote that was even
close to being good enough.
This is actually a very,
very good thing, though,
actually paraphrased.
Because this is important.
Because you want to
reduce JNI overhead
and actually using region
calls to copy data,
if you're going to
end up copying it.
And the finality is
it actually saves you
quite a bit of performance.
So here are the two
native functions
that copy data from
string into a buffer.
One of them does it
using the old school
way of doing Get,
Copy, and Release.
And the other one does it using
GetStringRegion, which is all
done at once, which is cool.
You're eliminating
some JNI calls.
And as you would expect--
oh, and the other thing
I was going to point out
here is that I actually
passed the length of
the string in as well.
Now I could, of course,
just pass the object
from the runtime and query it.
But obviously, that would
be another JNI call.
That would be a
huge waste of time.
And it turns out that
it's 20 to 30 times faster
just to pass an additional
parameter rather
than making another JNI call.
So as a general
rule, you're going
to always want to have
more parameters calling
into your native functions,
if you can possibly avoid ever
making a call back
into the runtime.
OK.
So here's how it
actually benchmarks
for copying string data.
And once again, this is
what we would expect,
that the GetStringRegion is
extremely close, actually,
between the two VMs
on the same hardware.
And GetStringChars is definitely
slower than both of them.
So region is
definitely a good one.
We'll put that on our scorecard.
So sharing structured data
between managed and unmanaged
code in the fastest
possible ways
isn't as easy as
sharing a soft drink.
You basically have two options.
You either use arrays
or direct byte buffers.
And it really comes
down to your use case.
Arrays are useful
if you're primarily
going to be accessing the
data from managed code.
But here's what our tips say
about direct byte buffers.
OK, this seems like a rather
uncommitted statement.
Like you'd think we could
do better than this.
Is it actually slow, like
on both of our run times,
on a real device?
Well, this is why I was like,
I've got to benchmark this one,
too.
And actually, it's not
terribly surprising,
but we see about two times
the raw JNI costs in order
to get the direct buffer
address access rather
than just using the
standard stuff that's
built into the runtime.
But you notice something
really interesting here
about this one.
And that if we actually go to
read back from the byte buffer,
it's actually three
times as expensive
to read from Dalvik
compared to using ART.
And this makes no sense.
We've seen in every
other call, we've
seen that Dalvik does this
much, much faster than ART.
So what's going on here?
Let's take a look at
what's going on actually
inside the code.
So basically, here's
what this looks like.
As you'd expect, this is
our direct byte buffer.
We can see that a regular
byte buffer is actually backed
by a Java array, while
a direct buffer is
backed by a memory block.
And so far, that's
exactly what we'd expect.
And here's how we start
actually reading an integer.
We can already see
that direct byte
buffer has an additional
level of indirection.
And based on the profiling I've
done, that probably costs us
about five nanoseconds.
And now we're somewhere.
Here's our ByteArray
implementation
and our MemoryBlock
both conveniently
in the same class.
And our MemoryBlock
version actually uses JNI.
So that explains why
direct is so much slower.
It's actually doing
a full JNI call just
to access this memory.
But why is ART so much faster?
Well, here's what that
native code calls into.
But it still doesn't tell
us why ART is faster.
The real magic
actually happens when
the JNI function is declared.
Because JNI overhead
is pretty high.
The runtime actually
short cuts it
into a fast mode
in certain cases.
So inside of ART's native
code, we declare the JNI call
with an exclamation
point to make it clear
that this is a potentially
dangerous function.
And now the thread gets to stay
in running mode without having
to switch to native.
So looking back at our
graph, our direct call
is about half the speed
of our byte buffer call.
And this is partially because
the version of the runtime
is actually using another trick.
It's really an inline intrinsic.
So we're never going to
get the kind of performance
out of our native call as
we will even without most
of the overhead
compared to what's
going on inside the runtime.
And partially because we
have a little bit of overhead
even in this kind of fast mode.
And this is about 60 nanoseconds
of overhead on a Nexus 5.
So it's not huge.
I mean, these are
tiny, tiny amounts.
You have to remember that
almost every single call you
make in Android ends up
going through one of these
eventually.
So the question is,
is there anything
we can do to avoid having
to make a call into JNI
for each Int we want to read?
And it turns out, there is.
We can copy the
entire array at once
and then get the
Int individually.
And now we're going to do some
pretty expensive stuff here.
So it only makes
sense if you're going
to be reading a lot
of structured data
from the byte buffer.
As always, you'll want to
profile just to make sure.
But once again, you
can see that this is
pretty awesome in terms of ART.
All right, so that was the
really, really scientific part
where I did lots
of benchmarking.
Let's get into actually
doing some fun stuff that's
maybe more practical.
So this slide
mostly demonstrates
why I'm not a design advocate.
But there are a lot of choices
to be made when using the NDK,
as well some updates
I'd like to highlight.
So we have a couple
of samples here.
And I wanted to show
you them, let's see,
on this phone I have up here.
And this is actually running
the End Developer Preview.
And there is a really
cool NDK sample
we have up here
called More Teapots.
And you can see that
in a normal mode,
it runs at 60 frames per second.
This thing uses geometry and
instancing to get actually
pretty decent performance
running even with fairly,
fairly a lot of teapots
flying around, basically.
And if we switch
over to the laptop,
you can see I've actually
taken a Systrace of this.
Now how many people here
have actually used Systrace?
I want to see a show of hands.
Because Systrace is like my
favorite tool ever, almost.
It is pretty awesome.
And it's kind of hard
to understand completely
what's going on when you're
just looking at it here.
So basically you can see that
inside of my More Teapots
application, I've
got Thread 9491.
And inside of that, I
can see EGL swap buffers
with damaged K char
and a Q buffer.
And then if we look also
inside of our SurfaceFlinger,
we can actually see that there's
a thread that's tied to that
as well that's responsible
for updating that Surface.
But we can do a lot better.
And let me show you a little
bit of what we can do.
OK, back to the
slides for a second.
Oh, I did want to go over
a few more things here.
But I'll do that later.
So what we can do to
start off is, let's get
rid of that ugly name.
We can actually name our
threads-- in this case,
the code is actually
attaching to the runtime.
So you can see here
that we actually
are using this
AttachCurrentThread
with AttachArgs.
And if we do that-- and let's
see if we can switch back to,
let me see, back to the laptop.
And I'll show you
two things here.
One is that I've
actually added something
called Too Many Teapots.
So this is like, instead of
512, which the regular demo has,
we're now looking at one that's
rendering 4,096 teapots, which
is actually way too much for
this poor, sad Nexus XP to do.
And you'll see a couple
of things interesting.
One is that we now see that
CPU 4 here is actually active.
And that's really, really bad.
Because CPU 4, it turns out,
is one of the high performance
CPUs that just
absolutely will cause
the device to
thermally throttle,
relatively quickly,
especially if someone has it
inside a nice
insulating case, which
of course, a lot of people do.
In fact, I did this
with and without cases.
And I got about 10%
better frame rates
once I took it out of a case.
That should give you an idea
of how these things actually
matter.
But the really cool
thing, as you can see,
if we go down here, it
should be here, maybe.
If it's not in this one,
it'll be in the next one.
This is supposed to
have a name thread.
This is the challenge with
getting Systrace is sometimes
I miss things.
But in any case, this will
actually show the thread name,
I swear.
OK, let me show you a
couple of other things
on the actual device itself.
So this is the too
many teapots demo.
As you can see, it's running
at about 12 frames a second,
which is really not very good.
But let's say we
absolutely wanted
to put 4,096 highly occluding
teapots into our game running
at some reasonable resolution.
How would we actually use
what's built into the NDK
to help us with that?
So we can switch
back to the slides.
I'll talk a little bit about
that and what we can do.
First of all, we
want to know what's
going on with performance.
So one of the cool things
that we've actually done
is we've actually created
a native trace API.
And this has actually been
in the platform ever since N.
So we've had begin
and end sections
for several versions, which
allows you to actually annotate
these Systraces, but now we
actually have a native API
to do it for you.
So we can actually see not
just like the KHR swap buffers
thing, but actually
individual sections of what's
going on in our engine, which
is really, really awesome.
And then you just do
an ATrace_beginSection,
ATrace_endSection.
It's pretty lightweight.
It's a lot lighter weight
than doing a log statement.
And you'll actually
see all of these things
show up in the graph
really, really nicely.
Now one of things that
we do really, really
easily is to reduce the
size of our render target.
Now what's cool is that
actually using the asset manager
APIs that are
built into the NDK,
we can actually get the
density of the screen.
And that's useful
because, obviously, we
might want to say our
application doesn't
need to render in anything
higher density than HDPI.
But that's nice because it
still actually preserves
the screen size.
It means that we're
actually really truly
giving the user a
decent experience
by using density as our target.
So let's switch back
to the phone here.
And I can show off the
first thing we can do here.
So this is just
scaling the target.
And obviously that's not a
very good user experience here,
but that's actually scaling
it based on density.
So I'm actually now rendering
the screen at old school HDPI,
just by using the density
metric there to scale.
But obviously,
that's not very good.
But we can do something better.
I can see we're getting
a good performance gain.
We're about 25
frames a second here.
However, we can actually
make it even faster
and actually make it a
better user experience
all at the same time
and by taking advantage
of the compositing engine inside
of SurfaceFlinger to do some
of the work for us and
actually save some memory
bandwidth in the process.
Yeah, let me switch back to
the slide here for one moment.
OK, so this is what
we actually do.
So once we've gotten the ratio
that we want, all we have to do
is call a native window,
get the right format,
because you don't want to change
the format of our native window
when we do this.
And then we can call
setBuffersGeometry.
And this is pretty cool
because what it'll actually
do for us is it'll automatically
scale that render target for us
and make things a lot happier
and a lot more friendly.
And actually when you're
looking at this in the device,
unless you're looking carefully,
it's really, really difficult
to notice what's going on here.
So we can switch
back to the phone,
and you can see what
I'm talking about.
So now once again, this is using
the internal compositing engine
to actually scale things up.
And you see, we're actually
doing better than we were even
rendering in just a little
corner of the window
because it's actually
using less fill.
And the other thing
that's really cool
about this is the
FPS is actually
being rendered using
a pop-up window.
And that pop-up
window is actually
running at the full
device resolution.
So that text that
you're seeing there
is actually rendered at
the super high DPI stuff.
And only the
background is actually
being rendered at
our lower resolution.
And the compositing engine
on a device like this
can do enough windows
that we're actually
getting the benefit of that.
So we have a HUD running
at really high res
and we have a background
running at a lower res.
And you can barely tell because
our eyes seeing characters
with a bunch of jaggies is
really noticeable to us.
But seeing a background
with a little lower
resolution-- not so bad.
This is actually a cool trick.
I don't think I've
ever seen anyone
use this in a shipping app.
But it can be done and
it works pretty well.
The one trick about
this one is it really
helps to be in immersive
mode when you're doing this
because the pull-downs
for the notification
and for the system
buttons at the bottom
actually also take windows.
So by going into immersive mode,
you actually free the system up
to have more windows to use
for your app in the compositor.
OK, so we can actually go
back to the slides now.
So another thing we
could do is actually
say, let's try to
cap the frame rate.
And we've actually added an
API called Choreographer.
And Choreographer is great.
It actually gives you
a callback whenever
there's [INAUDIBLE] coming in.
And up until N, it
was only available
inside of managed code.
But inside of N, we're
now opening it up for use
in all of your code
inside native code.
And there's a great
example of this, actually.
But let me actually show
you what that looks like.
We can switch back
to the device here.
Where is this one called?
Maybe I don't have
it on that screen.
Yeah, here we are.
And so now this is actually
using Choreographer
to lock things as close to 30
frames a second as possible.
And you can see there,
it's like 28, 29.
We're still getting some jank.
And you can see
that it's probably
running on the threads.
We're overheating
pretty quickly there.
But that's another
great thing you can do.
What's awesome
about Choreographer
is a lot of people are
like, their app or game
doesn't need to run at
60 frames per second.
And they'd much rather
save the user battery life,
not have the phone
overheat in their hand.
Users that actually respond on
comments are like, all right,
I played this game
and I was burning up,
and I had no battery
left an hour later.
And one easy thing
to do is say--
you can even make a slider,
saying, what are the frames,
do you want to limit the
frames per second of your game?
And for a lot of games,
that actually is huge.
And Choreographer allows you
to do that in an extremely,
extremely power-efficient way.
And what we're actually doing
in the code-- we can switch back
to the slides
here-- is basically
we're getting a frame callback.
And then we're simply,
every other frame callback,
we're swapping.
So it's pretty straightforward.
This is not the most
intelligent way of doing this
because you will get jitter.
If we're not actually able to
render at 30 frames per second,
this is kind of awful.
But as long as we're
actually able to do this,
this actually works pretty well.
And it's actually not that hard
to make it more complicated.
This is just the sample
that we ended up writing.
What's cool is if you
do go to that QR code,
that sample is live today.
And it's cool.
It actually uses Choreographer,
if you're on the latest
version of Android.
It uses EGL extensions on
a couple of older versions.
It actually goes down
to the Java version
of the API on earlier versions.
So you actually can see how
to do it all the way back to I
think 16 or something like
that, which is pretty nice.
So the sample is cool.
It's a little complicated.
I mean, it's not
using more teapots.
It's just a single teapot.
All right, so I showed you that.
And there we are.
We've got a little bit of
performance clawed back.
We're getting around 30
frames per second now
when we're not overheating
under the WolfVision here.
And this is even better
than we did with just
reducing the render target.
And we haven't had to add
a single non-native call
to do any of this.
Mind you, every single thing
that you were watching here
has been entirely
inside of the NDK,
which I'm very pleased about.
And I'm sure that our
developers are, too.
And let me show you one other
little thing that you can do
and that you might want to
do and why you might not
want to do that on
N. So how many of you
have heard about what we've
done with sustained performance
mode?
So sustained performance mode
is a feature mostly intended
for things like VR that
really, really require--
you don't want to drop frames.
You don't want the
device to overheat.
And so basically what
they do is they actually
try to put the device
in a mode where
it's never going to overheat.
Now the problem is, at that
rate under the conditions
they test on, you're not going
to get the highest performance.
So what I've done
is I've actually
taken a version of the app
that actually uses that API.
This has got all the
other optimizations
I've put in other than
the Choreographer one
because it just
gets too horrible.
And you can see, we're now
getting sustained performance.
It will never
overheat running this.
You can run this for hours.
But we're about 15
frames a second.
So you do give up a lot.
But if you absolutely need
sustained performance,
you can do that, especially
if you're doing things
like pro audio, where you're
really, really worried
about glitching.
This actually does pretty well.
So that's another
option for you.
Again, it's just a new window.
This is the first
actual call through JNI
that I've had to
make in all of this.
But as you can see, you
lose a lot of performance.
You really do have
to make a call there.
OK, we can go back
to the deck now.
All right, so there are
a lot of big choices
to also make when using the NDK.
Do you use Clang or GCC?
Do you use HardFP, 64-bit?
And I wasn't sure.
So I went and did
more benchmarking.
This was like a bear to
prepare for this thing.
So let's talk about performance.
If you look at Clang
versus GCC in 32-bit mode,
it's pretty much the same.
Like, sometimes, it's
exactly the same.
Literally, the Whetstone number
is identical between these two.
And they're within a percent
or so of any of the other two,
which is kind of what we expect.
And if you actually run your
code and run benchmarks on it
and you see anything different,
report it to our compiler team.
There's actually a place
where you can file issues
on our NDK site.
Let us know, because the
team is really, really,
very, very aggressive
about trying to make
the compiler perform well.
In 64-bit world, it's
actually also just as close.
GCC sometimes outperforms Clang.
Clang sometimes outperforms GCC.
But it is completely
not noticeable.
These are very
competitive compilers.
However, when we
look at build times,
this is our Zooshi application.
And this is kind of crazy,
because Zooshi actually
has tons of assets that
get built along with it.
And I didn't even pull them out.
I simply just said,
all right, I'm
going to do this the dumb way.
I'm just going to
build it from scratch.
Have it build all its assets.
Go through all of
its resource stuff.
And it was 1.4 times
the speed of GCC.
And you can see why our
internal Android team really
wanted to switch to Clang,
because I don't know if you've
ever heard of the
kind of machines
that it takes to actually build
Android, the whole platform,
but it's a lot of code.
So if you can improve your
compile speed by 1.4, 1.5,
1.6 times, that's a
huge productivity gain.
But also, there's
great sanitizers
that are built into Clang
that the team loves.
And actually the error
messages are kind of cool.
Although, GCC is making massive,
massive improvements there.
But this is still,
honestly, it's huge for me.
Now there's a big thing
about HardFP on ARM7.
How many people have
actually heard of this?
How many people actually use it?
OK, all I can say is every
time I've tried to use it,
I've run into bugs.
I've run into things
that don't work.
It's a really, really,
really hacky thing.
And it's not used internally
by the platform at all.
And because of
that, our Tools team
made the decision
to eliminate it.
So it is not in NDK r12.
Basically, if you're making
a whole bunch of calls
to math libraries, this
is where you'll actually
get hit by this.
What this is actually doing,
it's not actually not using
hardware floating point.
It simply has to do with the way
floating point parameters are
passed in function calls.
So if you look at the
assembly that gets generated,
it's a little more expensive.
But the truth is, if
function call overhead
is your problem in your
application and your floating
point intensive
application, you've
probably done something wrong.
Hopefully, you aren't
actually making a call
to do something extremely,
extremely simple
that you can just inline.
And that's the hope.
And most of the important math
functions will get inlined.
However, we know there
is some code that's
going to lose performance
because of this.
But honestly, once
we actually started
looking at the
problems with bugs
that people were having and
the fact that the platform
team wasn't using it-- and
when the platform doesn't use
something on
Android, it generally
doesn't get nearly as well
tested as it should be.
So it's really, really
important for us to do that.
That's what's so great about
what we've done with Clang
is that Clang is actually used.
You're getting the
exact same toolchain
for almost the first
time ever that's
used to build the platform.
And it's being very,
very well maintained.
It's also the same
version of the toolchain
that we're using inside
Google Data Centers.
And if you know the way we
test stuff in data centers,
is we roll it out to 10%.
See what's going on.
See if we hit any bugs.
Pull it back.
Change, do fixes.
And so we actually get to take
advantage of all the stuff
that they're doing to make
the data centers rock.
So it's actually really,
really good, I think,
that we're actually all united
around making one compiler
work really, really well.
And not that GCC
is dropping away.
If you do need it, if your code
doesn't compile, first of all,
let us know if you have a
problem compiling with Clang,
and we'll try to fix it.
And second of all, we are going
to keep GCC around for a while.
So it's not going away.
We're just not updating
to new versions.
If you're expecting to get
GCC 5, 4.9 is pretty much it.
So one final thing is if you
really want high performance,
definitely look at
doing a 64-bit ABI.
And really, I was
actually not 100%
sold on this because you do end
up using a little more memory.
And that does, of
course, mean you're using
a little more memory bandwidth.
But the extra registers that
you get that the compiler can
optimize around for
64-bit completely makes up
for any memory inefficiencies
is has, almost all of the time.
And we ran these
benchmarks a lot.
We found a whole bunch
of other benchmarks.
In general, if you have
something that's really,
really performance sensitive,
consider doing a 64-bit ABI.
Consider, if it's not
too big, just include it.
Of course, you can
include multiple ABIs
in multiple libraries
into any Android APK.
Or you can use
multi-APK to distribute
multiple different
versions of your app.
And again, it just works better.
And the best thing about
it is you already get
hard floating point when
you're running in on v8.
Finally x86 native.
The x86 emulation that is in
a bunch of Android devices
that allows them to run
arm code is awesome.
The fact that it
performs this well on,
admittedly, meaningless
benchmarks is pretty good.
But you can see like
with Whetstone, you
can be giving up easily
two-thirds of your performance
by not having an x86 build.
And so if you want to target
devices like the Nexus player
and like the Zen phone,
which are both pretty awesome
devices, definitely
consider actually
doing a native x86 version.
At least test it
because it really
makes a huge difference
in terms of battery life.
OK, so the Android runtime
does a lot of things
to make everything run fast.
On Android L and
M, it uses actually
ahead-of-time
compilation to bring
the performance
of byte code much
closer to native performance.
And on N, of course,
it uses a blend
of just-in-time and
ahead-of-time compilation.
And once again, it deals much,
much better with garbage.
And what we're seeing with ART,
is that a lot of times, you
don't actually need to
even go into native land.
Again, if all you're concerned
about is performance,
ART is actually doing
amazing, amazing stuff.
And you don't have
to worry about all
of these kinds of things.
So it's complicated,
as I said before.
That means that it's a little
more expensive to actually do
a JNI call.
And again, we have to
do synchronization.
And that's what's causing us
to actually have these delays.
So what's next?
Basically, here are two
links you can go to.
One of them, of course,
takes us into our NDK page.
We actually have NDK docs
online, which is amazing.
And we're updating them.
We have people who are actually
assigned to this project
to make it awesome.
Secondly, we have
great NDK samples.
And we're putting more
online all the time.
So if there's anything you
want that we don't have
a sample for, an API
that's not covered,
let us know we'll build samples.
[MUSIC PLAYING]